Avatar 2 the way of water is almost here
but we nearly got an entirely different
sequel instead here's the story James
Cameron almost told in less than two
weeks Avatar the way of water will
finally arrive in theaters the sequel
will tell the story of Jake Sully played
by Sam Worthington and natiri played by
Zoe Saldana as they form a life and
family together more than a decade after
the events of the first James Cameron
film but did you know that there was
actually another Avatar movie written
and planned before the way of water
which had a script in everything fans of
the growing science fiction franchise
have had to spend the past 13 years
waiting for a follow-up to be churned
out by 20th century Studios and Cameron
the aliens and Terminator director even
went so far as to throw out an entire
early draft made up of about 130 pages
because it wasn't subconscious enough
Cameron explained into the times UK in
September 2022 all films work on
different levels the first is surface
which is character problem and
resolution the second is thematic what
is the movie trying to say but Avatar
also works on a third level the
subconscious I wrote an entire script
for the sequel read it and realized that
it did not get to level three boom start
over that took a year
outstanding according to the official
Avatar the way of water synopsis Jake
and atiri's story will be rooted in
their relationship with their children
three of whom are Navi another is an
orphan human boy but how did Jake and
natiri get to this point and what
exactly happened during the years
between the Avatar and the way of water
films well that's where Avatar 1.5 comes
in as explained by Sam Worthington at a
recent Avatar the way of Water Press
event it's the Avatar movie that fans
will likely beg to be released for years
to come it supposedly provided an
in-depth look at Jake and the tiri's
early Warrior years as Navi Clan leaders
Worthington explained James Cameron gave
me a script that was Avatar 1.5 that
unto itself is amazing and detailed and
full of what they've kind of gone
through over that Gap part of that story
was about them being Warriors and taking
on the battles of other clans and things
like that it gave gave us a good jumping
off point to understand how to fill in
that Gap that's missing to be honest
most people would have stuck on that one
but not Cameron according to Worthington
Cameron ultimately wanted to explore a
more natural extension of the Jake and
iteri love story through their children
and family struggles rather than making
an avatar war movie with way of water
the path for the Avatar franchise has
been officially charted however there is
hope that Cameron's Avatar 1.5 could be
adapted for a different medium or maybe
it already has consider Cameron's
original 130 page script for the sequel
which he threw out because it failed to
tackle the subconscious titled The High
Ground the script has been repurposed
into a dark horse graphic novel Cameron
told total film magazine we figured out
a way to restructure the elements that
we needed to distribute across the first
two of the sequels and relaunched it in
a completely different way you'll be
able to see that interim battle that
took place between movie E1 and movie 2.
The High Ground has been explicitly
dubbed as a prequel to The Way of Water
by Dark Horse though it's unclear if the
repurposed script is the one Sam
Worthington described as Avatar 1.5 the
graphic novel is set a decade after the
first film and focuses on natiri and
Jake's family reeling with humans
returning to Pandora this direction
sounds largely different from what
Worthington described which was natiri
and Jake battling with other Navi Clans
perhaps that script Worthington saw will
get the graphic novel treatment as well
or be adapted into a novel keep in mind
that Cameron Inked a deal with penguin
Random House in 2017 to publish several
books in the Avatar universe according
to Los Angeles Times either way fans
will likely be blown away by what's up
on the big screen when way of water hits
theaters on December 16th
let's get it done
[Music]